speaking of alireza you actually scored
an important victory uh against him take
us through that game and what were the
critical moments
did he just lose the game with one move
in the opening
yeah i mean the critical moment was on
on move three
i i played a great move here i played
knight f6 okay and
after that i don't know what one can do
to berlin of course yeah
and yeah something went wrong for him i
i mean he he was
he was on his own and you actually
played this position with the white
pieces yeah yeah
yeah i took on c6 and then d4
so i knew something about it i was
trying to remember what happens i mean
e4 e5 queen g7
cd bishop b6 a4 was the game a4 a5 and
knight c4
and this is all i remembered and how
black is supposed to play this i
couldn't remember but
um but d4 came as a shock immediately
because i didn't understand i mean
i didn't understand why i can't play ed4
also but then i thought
why not eliminate the bishop immediately
i mean you yeah i was thinking d takes
e5 is probably the
like the best move but
you've accepted like a very bad position
from the opening
so like psychologically it's really
tough to play this you want you want to
at least sack upon and try to make
create some mess on the board which is
what he should try to do
and then you guys got to this position
it did feel like after up to b5 this was
an invitation to you i thought maybe
because rook b3 i wasn't
i suddenly realized i wrote b3 queen g7
and queen b1 is a little bit annoying
a because a5 is a threat knight c45
bishop a6
knight b6 i was trying to figure this
out bishop f1 knight
d7 or
d5 i don't know then i take and
you have queen a1 yeah i also have rook
d8 which is easy but queen a1 is nice as
well and bishop to c4 you can you don't
have time to take whenever yeah this is
sort of the stuff i was looking at and
then he shocked me from b5
i mean this is uh
yeah he was just going all in this was
desperation
faviano slow start in day one minus one
in that one plus one in day two now
you're back to uh fifty percent how do
you feel about your chances no overall
it was a good day i think i i could have
maybe done two and a half today
because i i don't know if i ever had
winning chances against lanier but it
was definitely definitely seemed like he
was in danger and i also thought i gotta
slide something against levon in the
last game not much but uh
but a little something
okay i don't think i had any like
serious winning chances but definitely
some chances to push in the remaining
games still a good result today
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
fabian thank you